The video of "I Won't Let You Down," we shot the whole thing in Japan.
There's an incredible, incredible creative director named Mori Harano...
...and I'd seen his work years ago and I met him in France.
Finally, we found a way to work with Mori,...
...we came to Japan and worked with Honda, so we spent a month in Japan.
This video was largely inspired by the legendary choreographer Busby Berkeley...
...who did, in the early 20th century, did these amazing musical numbers...
...with dozens or sometimes hundreds of dancers.
Another inspiration for this video were the big mass games that,...
...you know, there are some of these crazy North Korean mass games.
But there's also, there's an old Japanese sport of mass games,...
...where groups of people do this crazy choreography and routines together.
So to try to come up with our own version of that,...
...and to imagine big patterns and big shapes,...
...we used a computer program to previsualize it.
It was so fun to play with that we're gonna try to actually...
...make a version of the video that you can, that's interactive...
...and users can actually make their own version of the video.